is there a world where there's more
Destiny's Child music I don't know haha
only one it is up to you
oh no you guys too much pressure too
much pressure we I will say we have made
incredible music in the past and I don't
know let can we like have surprises in
this day and age surprise
so maybe I'm just saying like I just
find it so interesting everybody always
wants to know in advance oh and like I
know every time like there's a decision
to be made for myself and the ladies to
do something it's usually a surprise and
our fans have always been so supportive
yeah awesome like I like to give them
surprises I got nothing on my sleeve I
promise you nothing on my sleeve but
yeah like if it wouldn't say anything if
it were to happen though you think it
would be a surprise is what you're
saying just confirming I guess if I'm
worried they're not not here I'm not
saying anything oh my god the fans just
love you guys together so much and I
think that's where this comes from
thank you so much Kelly Rowland not say
no to more Destiny's Child music but
she's playing coy on rumors Michelle
Williams is the butterfly on this season
of the masked singer there's all these
hints that it's her and so we just want
to know if you if you know anything I
don't know anything you don't know
anything okay
is she if Michelle did not tell me I'm
gonna be really upset people really
think it's her now I have to call her
yeah we want to call her right now me me
no no no I can't call right now oh my
gosh so imma be mad if she's gonna be
mad for you I thought we can you may
know I'm gonna actually text her right
after this okay let us know what she
says I can't do that right though right
that's a part that's a whole party if
she hasn't told me now oh my god I know
I know I really wanted you to call her
all right we have to wait for answers on
that but Kelly's also dishin on her son
Titans your son is
train 5 he is turning he's turning 5
November this November is no longer he's
warning you guys planning and how does
he handle the holidays it's love oh he
loves the holidays it's his favorite
time of the year and he also knows that
his birthday is very close to Christmas
so for his birthday he wants a reptile
party he's asked me to bring in snakes
and lizards I don't like snakes
I don't like lizards and I have to
pretend for my son that I'm not afraid
of snakes and lizards and how to handle
those
um I've breathing deeply and call it a
day I'm just like oh yeah that's like
you see a 1 2 3 4 get this thing back
you know that kind of thing because I
don't want him to be afraid I don't want
him to sense my fear sure and he's not
he loves it and get this he's been
learning from Beyonce's daughter Blue
Ivy our Titan boy Ivy having play dates
yet oh yeah yeah she's showing him the
ropes
will she be at the reptile party I mean
we all like me and all of my friends
like we all are like in each other's
lives and in our children's lives and
then our children's are in each other's
lives so it's incredible it's incredible
to be able to grow up with you know your
friends and sisters and be able to have
relationships and your children have
relationships that's really a blessing
that's what friendship and and life is
all about yeah and Kelly's got a lot to
celebrate right now her and hubby Tim
just celebrated five years of marriage
what do you love most about him after
five years um that he is still my best
friend we still like figuring everything
out like figuring marriage out like it
is
yes yeah yeah marriage is definitely a
challenge but you also have to think
about it like you're experiencing this
with the person like you Noah's got you
and that's truly a blessing to know
that especially in this business because
you know honesty someone really true is
like really hard to come across yeah
he's just one of those incredible people
she's also got a lifetime holiday movie
coming out merry little Christmas yes
this is based off true events that
happened to you yes okay well tell me
about this Christmas in the Roland house
a little bit
well what basically happened is my
family moved into our dream homes and we
were so excited and I was I told my
husband I said we have to have the whole
family here you know the way they doing
all the Christmas movies and he was like
no that's not a good idea he's like you
know they have set design and somebody
to help them you know everything uh he's
like that's not how it is in our
household I just know how our family
will be and so sure enough he was right
and my beautiful well once all creme
chairs just kind of turned into this
nice red and green cookie icing you know
it just took on a whole new you know
decor yeah I guess you will per my
nieces who thought it would be a good
idea like after they decorate their
couldn't they just kind of you know wipe
the one that yours our kids it's okay it
happens hence the red and the green kids
around the green and you know another
family member just decided so you know
it's still a big gulp coca-cola cup all
over my $10,000 couch so it's crazy
these things happen and I remember
telling one of the execs over at life
time she's like we will rework this
story but I love it she's like you have
to do it before it's a wonderful yeah
I'm Christmas specials oh we have that
how do you handle disaster I freaked out
yeah I breathe which is actually what my
character Jackie little does uh-huh she
completely Brees tries to come back now
so she doesn't appear like really OCD
yeah I am absolutely OCD um and that's
basically what happens you know she's a
Jackie little as my character a merry
little Christmas I'm OCD I'm a tech
entrepreneur I have this really cool
experience that comes up where this
company who wants to buy a
any that I've made basically they want
to see how I interact with my family for
the holidays and one disaster after
another happen I love it
what does your husband think now that
it's turned into a movie and he was the
one wasn't like and I told you so it's
the oh my gosh I can't believe you
turned that into a movie yeah
[Music]